(dramatic music)
- It is time to settle into
that groove into your couch
and maybe invest in those
surround sound speakers
that nobody can afford
because Warner Bros. just announced
that they're releasing their
entire 2021 slate of movies
in theaters and on HBO Max.
So what exactly does
this mean for all of us?
We're gonna break it all down for you
right now on The Ketchup.
So Warner Bros. dropped this bomb
with the hottest of
sizzle reels last week.
We're talking "The Matrix
4," "Godzilla vs. Kong,"
"Dune," "In The Heights,"
"The Suicide Squad," "Space
Jam: A New Legacy" and more,
all from the comfort of your own home,
provided, of course, you
are an HBO Max subscriber,
the odds of which we're
betting just heavily increased.
And fans were already
stoked and frankly shocked
that "Wonder Woman 1984"
is coming out on HBO Max on Christmas Day,
the same time it's coming out in theaters.
Now, the decision to
simulcast big premieres
is being framed by Warner
Bros. as the best solution
for an industry that's hemorrhaging money
from delayed release dates
and needs to try something
new to keep fans engaged.
One thing worth mentioning:
While these movies are free to watch
for HBO Max subscribers,
they are removing any kind
of free trial, and get this:
Each will only be available
for 31 days on HBO Max
before going to other
video-on-demand rental platforms.
You better start charging your friends
you shared that password with.
Just kidding.
- Your username is "password?"
- It was just easier.
- Now, all of this sounds
like a good compromise
to audiences. Movie theaters? Not so much.
AMC Theaters is currently
trying to stay afloat themselves
and did not appreciate Warner
offering potential ticket
buyers access to their upcoming catalog.
Now, AMC does have a history with studios
trying to cut them out of the deal.
In April, they threatened to
ban all Universal releases
from their theaters
after "Trolls World Tour" was
released on video-on-demand
instead of waiting until
theaters were open again.
But that situation led to a
then unprecedented agreement
between AMC and Universal to stream films
after a 14-day window.
So maybe these are just some
hard-bargaining tactics.
I mean, AMC is acting
more like ABC, am I right?
- Always be closing.
- Now Warner and Universal
aren't the only ones to dabble
with at-home releases.
Disney also flirted with a similar model
earlier this year,
releasing the live-action "Mulan"
on its own streaming platform, Disney+,
the same day it came out in theaters,
and will go head-to-head
with "Wonder Woman" on
Christmas with Pixar's "Soul,"
which, unlike "Mulan," will
be free for subscribers.
You got to think this may
all just be a response
to Christopher Nolan's "Tenet,"
which came out exclusively
in theaters earlier this fall
after many delays
and suffered at the box
office, leaving many Nolan fans
still wondering what
"Tenet" is even about.
I mean, what really happens
in his movies anyway?
- Dream within a dream.
- Hm, I'm impressed.
- Warner Bros. seems to be offering
the best of both worlds:
No extra charges beyond
your HBO Max subscription
and the chance for fans to
see the movies they love
without worrying for their safety.
You know, like in the
good old days of 2019.
And while no one is exactly thrilled
at what the WB announcement
seems to predict -
another year of staying
cooped up at home -
at least one director remains optimistic.
When asked about the Warner decision
during a recent interview,
"Ocean's 11" director Steven Soderbergh,
who recently signed a deal
to release films on HBO Max,
reminded us not to panic.
"The theatrical business
is not going away.
It's all gonna come back...
because let's be clear:
there is no bonanza
in the entertainment industry
that is the equivalent
of a movie that grosses
a billion dollars or more theatrically."
Christopher Nolan also happened
to chime in on the decision,
calling it "a real bait and switch,"
which is likely the same sentiment
as "Dune" and "Godzilla vs.
Kong"'s Legendary pictures,
who are allegedly
threatening to sue Warner
over a lack of communication
about the decision to move
their movies to the streaming service.
More on that news as we get it.
(plane roaring)
- Brace for impact!
Well, let's throw it over to you guys now.
what do you think about Warner Bros.'
big announcement?
Are you planning on getting HBO Max
if you haven't already,
or are you holding out to see
Godzilla vs. King Kong on the big screen?
Let us know all your thoughts and feelings
in the comments section,
and of course, if you want more movie
or streaming news,
head on over to RottenTomatoes.com.
And if you already know
which of Warner's movies
are must-sees and which
you plan on skipping harder
than a scratched Blu-ray,
let's keep the conversation going
in our fan group on Facebook.
As always, thank you so much
for watching The Ketchup.
My name's Naz Perez,
and we'll see you in the next video.
Bye.
(upbeat music)